Another Thing Doctor Bright is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation:
Dr. Bright is not allowed to feed anything
with peanut butter to Kain.
And no, we don’t mean SCP-073, that’s
Cain with a C.
This is Dr. Kain Pathos Crow, a legendary
SCP Foundation researcher who, through some
anomalous accident, got turned into a dog
with human-level intelligence and ability.
Dr. Bright is no stranger to being an animal
thanks to his body-swapping necklace, so he
may want to treat his colleague to a nice
spoonful of peanut butter as an act of solidarity
- After all, peanut butter without xylitol
is safe for dogs to eat.
But no matter how funny Dr. Bright thinks
it is, the O5 Council is not amused by the
constant sounds of Dr. Crow trying to lick
peanut butter off the roof of his mouth during
staff meetings.